Biden US President Joe Biden is vowing
retaliation after a drone attack killed
three US soldiers and injured dozens of
others he's blaming Iranian proxies I do
hold respon them responsible in the
sense that they're supplying the weapons
to the people of D I don't think we need
a wider war in the Middle East that's
not what I'm looking for the strike was
claimed by an umbrella group the Islamic
resistance in Iraq at the Pentagon
Tuesday officials said they haven't
pinpointed which action within the group
launched the attack but one of the most
prominent katab Hezbollah reportedly
said it will no longer Target US forces
in the region out of respect to the
Iraqi government us officials were
skeptical of that claim actions speak
louder than words um you know there has
been three attacks to my knowledge uh
since the 28th of
January uh and I'll just leave it there
so I typically make it a practice not to
respond to statements from terrorist
organizations from the podium here we
will hold accountable any organization
that we find to be responsible for
attacks on us Personnel in the region
President Joe Biden is coming under
increasing pressure to strike back now
some Republicans have even called for
him to strike inside of Iran that said
for months this Administration has been
saying the biggest concern they have is
that this will lead to a wider war and
it seems fairly clear that striking
inside of Iran would make that more
likely rather than less Patty Coan Al
jazer at the state
department make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer